Hello.
This is Six Minute
English from BBC
Learning English. I'm Neil.
Beth?
What are you doing?
Get off your phone!
Oh, sorry!
And I'm Beth.
Are you addicted to social media?
It wouldn't be a surprise.
With so many different apps
out there,
Snapchat, TikTok,
and the latest, Threads,
it's easy to spend a lot more time
on your phone than ever before.
Yes, I don't think I'm addicted,
but I definitely spend more time
on social media than I'd like to.
However, there are plenty
of studies out there looking
at how social media affects
mental health with some saying
it can be as addictive as gambling.
Research in the US has found
that adolescents who spend more than
three hours a day on social media
have double the risk of developing
depression and anxiety. An adolescent
is someone aged ten to nineteen,
between childhood and adulthood.
With that in mind,
it's no wonder parents are worried.
To help with this, the US is currently
in the process of regulating
social media apps for teenagers.
Some scientists think the UK
should do the same.
There has been growing agreement
among health experts about
the negative chronic health effects
of social media use on teenagers.
They have revealed in surveys that
social media makes them feel worse
about their body image and
64% of teens have said
they are regularly exposed to
hate-based content. In this programme,
we'll be discussing how
social media affects teenagers and,
as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first
I have a question for you, Beth.
The app Snapchat is a very common way
that teenagers communicate these
days.
This is
partly because messages
and photos disappear
after a certain time period.
But what percentage of thirteen to
twenty-four year olds use Snapchat?
Is it: a) 70%, b) 80% or c) 90%.
Hmm, I'll guess 80%.
OK, Beth. I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme.
A lot of social media platforms, such
as TikTok, work
by showing and suggesting similar
accounts and content to those
someone has already searched
for. Professor Devi Sridhar,
the Chair of global public health
at the University of Edinburgh, thinks
this can be concerning, as she told
BBC World Service Programme,
Inside Science. And this
is worrying, for example,
with young girls and eating disorders,
that they're being fed that
in an addictive way and the algorithm
saying, 'Oh, they like that content.
We want to keep giving it to them
because it keeps them on their phones
and I think that's the really vital
message here, of any of these apps,
is that their revenue comes
from advertising.
Teenagers are being fed content
in a way that is addictive.
If you are fed something,
it means you're given something.
In this case,
it refers to content, not food.
The content is addictive
because social media users algorithms.
Algorithms are a complex set of rules
and calculations that prioritise and
personalise the content a user sees.
But we need to remember that
social media platforms use algorithms
to keep users on the platforms
for as long as possible
because their revenue comes from
advertising. Revenue is the money
a company earns. They're
paid by other companies
to use the social media space
to promote their products.
This could be seen as social media
platforms prioritising making money
over the mental health of users –
a worry for parents.
Professor Debbie Sridhar talked
about the challenges
of having a teenager addicted
to social media on BBC
World Service Programme,
Inside Science.
And so I think
the challenge here, as a parent, listening
to this is what you do about it.
And I think the onus has been put
on parents and concerned adults
to find solutions on their own.
And that means debates
with your child over
what are you are on, are you using this,
but it's a losing battle
because it's their
entire social network.
Professor Sridhar says
that, when it comes to helping
teenagers navigate social media,
the onus has been put on parents
to find solutions.
The onus means
the responsibility or duty.
Parents need to be able to challenge
their children when they need
to, even if this is
a losing battle, a fight
they cannot win as teenagers have
their entire life on social networks.
OK Beth. I think it's time
I reveal the answer to my question.
I asked you
what percentage of thirteen to
twenty-four year olds use Snapchat.
And I said it was 80%.
And that was,
I'm sorry to say, the wrong answer.
Actually 90%
of people aged between thirteen
and twenty four
use Snapchat –
quite a lot.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we have learned from this programme,
starting with adolescent –
a person aged ten to nineteen,
between childhood and adulthood.
If you are fed content,
you are given content.
This is what the social media platform
offers you automatically rather than
what you search for yourself.
Algorithms are a complex set of rules
and calculations that prioritise
and personalise the content a user
sees. Revenue
is the money
a company earns which could come
from sales or advertising. If the
onus is on someone,
it's their responsibility or duty.
And finally,
a losing battle is a fight
you cannot win. Once again
our six minutes are up.
Join us again soon for more
useful vocabulary here at Six Minute
English. Goodbye
for now. Bye.